bonjour bienvenue dans file echo
l'émission qui revient sur l'actualité
économique locale on commence tout de
suite avec les grandes lignes de cette
émission nouvelles réactions sur la
situation financière de l'université
saint quentin en yvelines versailles les
syndicats appellent à manifester le 12
décembre
ça y est la houlette de luc soient
nationaux ouvert ses portes hier fin des
travaux pour les riverains qui ont pu
découvrir les lieux nous y étions et
puis enfin les grands prix de
l'innovation se tenait ce lundi à paris
parmi les entreprises franciliennes en
lice des yvelinois nous suivrons leur
aventure dans notre dossier la semaine
expert comptable commissaire aux comptes
des métiers méconnus la 13e édition de
la journée pédagogique sur ces métiers
du chiffre a permis à 600 jeunes d'en
apprendre un peu plus nous invité
laurent courquin et antoine le goujon
soir tous des experts comptables et
commissaires aux comptes reviendront sur
leur parcours et nous pourrons parler du
coût de ses deux métiers dans un instant
où passent juste avant à l'actualité
économique de la semaine
le 12 décembre c'est la date choisie par
l'intersyndicale de l'université de
versailles saint quentin pour appeler à
manifester les syndicats réclament un
plus grand soutien du ministère alors
que l'université affiche un déficit de 4
millions d'euros mais alors acquis qui
peut-on accuser à qui la faute les
syndicats pointent du doigt surtout les
partenariats public privé un reportage
de catherine mulato et patrick jacques
de dixmude
professeurs étudiants personnels réunis
en assemblée générale ils parlent tous
d'une même voix alors que l'université
de versailles-saint-quentin accuse un
déficit de 4 millions d'euros le
ministère a accordé une rallonge
budgétaire allouée est ce qu mais les
économies décidées inquiète
l'intersyndicale ce qui nous fait peur
c'est devoir payer l'austérité
effectivement pendant 20 ans et que les
solutions qu'on nous propose pour
effectivement rattraper ce trou énorme
quand même un don on a pris connaissance
assez tardivement
premier effectivement les conditions
d'études des étudiants se traduise à
terme par des licenciements de
personnels contractuels premièrement
s'il ya eu erreur de gestion et ça c'est
évidemment au ministère de le dire c'est
nous qui pouvons qu'y pouvons le savoir
ce n'est pas une raison pour faire payer
aux étudiants et aux personnels ces
heures de gestion passée deuxièmement ce
que nous voulons dire c'est que au delà
des problèmes de gestion locale 1 de
l'université il y avait un contexte
général un véhicule n'est ce pas la
seule université à être en déficit et ne
sera pas la seule reste en déficit ni en
2013 2014
et ça évidemment là dessus d'un ministre
de communique beaucoup moins
l'intersyndicale met en cause l les
partenariats public privé ils ont été
notamment signé dans le cadre de la
construction de l'ufr des sciences
demandons la dénonciation même pas la
mise à plat la dénonciation puisque ces
partenariats public privé sont
complètement inadaptés à la gestion du
patrimoine
immobilier public tout simplement parce
qu'il nous empêche de planifier et
d'avoir les investissements et de
redonner à la puissance publique le
libre choix de ses décisions l'ensemble
des ppp aujourd'hui sont mauvais pour
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
et nous demandons donc à ce que le
ministère ait de l'alluré est ce qu à
sortir de son pvp notamment de pvp donc
le pp économies d'énergie et le pvp qui
concerne le bâtiment en médecine aa par
bouygues parmi ceux qui se sont
mobilisés en faveur de ces partenariats
valérie pécresse ancien ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
l'actuel député des yvelines défend ce
type de contrat tout en pointant du
doigt le manque de formation des
gestionnaires d'université après si un
partenariat est mal négocié si un
partenariat est mal gérée eh bien ça
peut tourner à la catastrophe
6 mais ce n'est pas l'outil lui-même
qu'il faut qu on allait ce qu'il faut
c'est en amont bien géré les dossiers et
ça nous remet sur la vraie question qui
est est ce qu'il y a dans l'univers
c'est versailles saint quentin
suffisamment de personnel qualifié et
suffisamment de moyens pour permettre à
l'université d'avoir les motards de
pouvoir réaliser toutes ses ambitions et
à cette question je pense que
malheureusement la réponse aujourd'hui
et et non le président de l'université
jean luc vestiaire doit présenter son
budget à la mi décembre en attendant
l'intersyndicale appelle à manifester le
12 décembre à 10 heures devant le
rectorat version
la houlette de luxe one national ouvert
ses portes hier aux clayes-sous-bois le
concept des marques de luxe qui
proposent dans le rayon des collections
passées à prix bradés 24 6 millimètres
carrés de magasins qui ont pu découvrir
les premiers visiteurs des lieux nous
sommes allés recueillir leurs premières
réactions
encore c'est un joli c'est à côté de moi
c'est un oui voilà jolie balle à ses
formidables sûr on est enchanté en
anglais d'arrivée c'est magnifique jeu
magnifique oui j'espère que ça va ça va
fonctionner le nom du magasin puis le
comment comment dirais-je les marques et
c'était à quoi c'est très intéressant
première impression de salaire très joli
mais alors deuxième impression je fais
très fort alors bon je vais bien mais et
quand il va pleuvoir des cordes je ne
sais vraiment pas ce qui va se passer je
pense que le fait d'avoir tout ça là à
côté de la maison masse et je les ai vus
sortir de j'ai vu sortir de terre en
fête et là je vois qu'ils ont fait ça à
l'arraché à la fin quoi mais c'est sympa
je pense que ça va ramener ces nouveaux
en tous les cas et tout ce qui est
nouveau ça attire tout le temps les gens
alors pour le moment tous les magasins
ne sont pas installés les ouvriers sont
encore sur les lieux par contre il
restera à ciel ouvert à terme 112
boutiques devraient être présentes pour
accueillir 5 millions de visiteurs
principalement des touristes nous avons
également rencontré la responsable d'une
des boutiques
one les jeunes représentent quand même
a produit un centre très qualitatif sur
lesquels beaucoup d'espoirs sont fondés
en magasin à l'usiné on est 30 % moins
cher que les prix pratiqués en boutique
c'est la moyenne donc on sait que les
gens sont très attentifs et en ce moment
à tout ce qui est tout ce qui est pris
donc je pense que ça peut être ça peut
avoir un très très bel impact
le rapport bailly a été remis lundi au
gouvernement travaill ait ou non le
dimanche sous quelles conditions des
éléments qui sont encore source de
division l'objectif avec ce rapport est
d'aboutir à une nouvelle loi courant
2014 il s'intitule vers une société qui
s'adapte en gardant ses valeurs lui
rapportera donc choisi en amont
aménagements pardon des règles et non
une libéralisation et premier à le
réclamer sont évidemment les magasins de
bricolage en attendant la loi une
dérogation leur est accordée jusqu'en
2015 je vous propose d'écouter la
réaction de 110 lopin porte parole du
collectif les bricoleurs du dimanche
elle intervenait lundi dans le 7 8 on
voit que monsieur veiller au moins
étudié le sujet on voit que le
gouvernement a entendu qu'il nous donne
quand même un décret provisoire
cependant c'est vraiment pas une
victoire puisqu'il faudra quand c'est la
loi de 2014 qui sera vraiment
décisionnaire sur le sujet alors pour
l'instant le rapport va pas donc le
complètement dans votre sens justement
sur cette ouverture du dimanche puisque
à priori et rejeté l'idée de créer de
nouvelles dérogations permanentes pour
le secteur du bricolage quel est votre
avis alors effectivement nous ce qu'on
demande c'est un décret pour le secteur
du bricolage et nous ne l'avons pas
obtenu cependant
il s'agit dorénavant de voir les
ententes au niveau
territorial et au niveau social donc au
niveau social nous nous avons tout ce
qui va bien parce qu'on a un salaire
majoré un deuxième jour un repos
compensateur et que c'est du volontariat
maintenant il faut voir ce que donneront
les acteurs territoriaux raison puisque
ce qui nous intéressait réellement
c'était l'ouverture de magasins de
bricolage en ile de france et que si
c'est si c'est ça que visent les accords
territoriaux ce sera ce sera une partie
gagnée
la semaine dernière le gouvernement a
annoncé l'inversion de la courbe du
chômage -0 6% au niveau des yvelines ce
taux est resté quant à lui stable pas
d'évolution des données brutes par
rapport à septembre mais les chiffres
publiés ce matin par l'insee sont moins
bons plus 0,1 point soit 10 5% de
chômage au niveau national au troisième
trimestre le taux le plus élevé depuis
1997 nous passons maintenant à
l'entretien
hier se tenait la troisième édition de
la journée pédagogique sur les métiers
du chiffre aux chaînés 600 jeunes de la
région ile de france ont pu découvrir
les métiers d'expert comptable et
commissaire aux comptes des métiers qui
souffre d'un déficit d'image alors que
les filières promettent de nombreuses
embauches aujourd'hui et demain la
compagnie des commissaires aux comptes
organise également ces seizièmes à 6
autant de raison de parler de ces
métiers inconnu nous recevons sur ce
plateau laurent courquin bonsoir et
antoine logo soit vous êtes tous deux
experts comptables et commissaires aux
comptes vous cumuler les deux fonctions
tout d'abord lent peut-être oloron pour
qu'un est ce que vous nous expliquer la
différence en fait entre ces deux
métiers d'accor alors donc je vais
commencer par expert comptable expert
comptable donc cette j'allais dire le
conseiller le plus proche des
entreprises et celui qui assiste le chef
d'entreprise dans l'élaboration de
toutes ces données financières il le
conseille également sous les aspects de
la fiscalité également tout ce qu'ils
vont faire la législation sociale dont
qui l'accompagnent en définitive le chef
d'entreprise et ils aident à produire
toute l'information financière
voilà en ce qui concerne le commissaire
aux comptes le commissaire aux comptes
c'est une personne qui certifie en fait
toutes les données financières qui sont
produites par une entreprise et qui sont
diffusées donc à l'extérieur autrement
dit il est le garant en définitive donc
de la sécurité financière de la
fiabilité financière des informations
qui sont données on pouvait finalement
cumulé ces deux fonctions quand ça n'est
pas pour la même entreprise absolument
puisqu'on ne peut pas se contrôler soi
même sur ce que nous avons fait
elle aura donc la filière n'a pas
forcément bonne image et pourtant elle a
un bel avenir devant elle vous prévoyez
de nombreux recrutements combien
exactement alors on a fait des
statistiques et il ressort de ces de ces
statistiques que dans les dix ans à
venir on a besoin de dix mille expert
comptable et commissaire aux comptes
donc c'est une filière qui embauchent
c'est une filière
dont les jeunes sont les bienvenus on a
donc comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure lancée la 13e édition de graines
de cac donc hier dans les yvelines il y
avait 600 jeunes inscrits 550 étaient
présents et ils ont tous manifesté un
intérêt particulièrement fort pour notre
profession ce qui est bien parce que ça
montre qu au moins nous redonnerons
l'image d'autres métiers je regrette de
cas qu'on peut en parler quand même de
taxer c'est cette petite d'aidé alors ce
sont des livres est finalement illustré
avec des explications des illustrations
une petite bd nous devrions voir bientôt
sur sur l'écran donc c'est une petite bd
qui existait déjà pour les experts
comptables la nouveauté cette année
c'est pour g de kaki graines de
commissaires aux comptes
nous avons rencontré le vice président
de la compagnie de versailles il nous en
dit quelques mots je vous propose de
l'écouter
ça arrive dans un instant
c'est de leur parler avec un langage qui
soit pas justement le langage que nous
avons l'habitude d'utiliser et qui peut
paraître même pour des entreprises même
pour des entreprises ça peut paraître de
temps en temps un peu trop technique
voire un peu trop jargon et l'idée avec
7 cette plaquette et est de s'adresser à
un public non averti de leur parler
d'une façon à la fois précise et simple
de ce que recouvre ce métier et de ce
recours recouvre aussi la façon
d'accéder à ce métier parce que ce qui
est important c'est de les motiver pour
y arriver à ceux disponibles chez tous
les experts comptables et commissaires
aux comptes qui peuvent en avoir de
disposition sous format papier c'est
disponible aussi sur les sites de la
compagnie des commissaires aux comptes
de versailles ou de paris où l'ordre des
experts-comptables et donc cette fois-ci
non pas sous une version papier mais
sous une version électronique a attiré
de plus donc plus de gènes est ce qu'il
ya donc des besoins vous le disais 10000
postes et également pour rajeunir
peut-être un peu la filière
c'est s'adapter aux nouveaux outils
quel est l'intérêt finalement d'avoir
des
janin qui arrive bien sûr c'est parce
qu'on vit une période de mutation cette
mutation elle est particulièrement dans
toutes les activités liées à
l'information et l'information
financière en fait partie donc ce qui
veut dire qu'effectivement nous avons
besoin de jeunes pour pouvoir parler
aussi à des jeunes chefs d'entreprise et
particulièrement sur les nouvelles
technologies donc ça c'est déjà
effectivement un point la deuxième
raison pour laquelle nous nous
souhaitons et nous devons effectivement
nous avons besoin de recruter donc des
jeunes c'est simplement parce qu'il ya
toujours traditionnellement dans ces
métiers une rotation autrement dit donc
des gens qui au bout de 4-5 ans
choisissent une autre filière après que
nous ayons bien informés qu'ils aient
acquis une expérience extrêmement riche
enrichissante ils ont besoin
effectivement nous avons besoin d'avoir
effectivement de nouveaux jeunes pour
pouvoir effectivement donc continuer à
exercer donc nous mais qui a été
d'ailleurs votre dans votre carrière
l'entreprise
a déjà attiré à la base alors à la base
ce qui m'a attiré comme métier donc moi
j'ai une
formation d'école de commerce et
effectivement ce métier au départ donc
m'intéressait parce que ça m'a permis
d'acquérir des méthodes de travail qui
me permet finalement d'aborder quel que
soit le problème une technique en
définitive devant une foisonnement
d'informations d'arriver à canaliser et
analysé effectivement une situation et
puis c'est vrai qu'au bout d'un certain
temps j'étais assez curieux de voir ce
qui se passait en entreprise donc c'est
vrai que j'ai travaillé pendant quatre
cinq ans en entreprise mais finalement
ce qui m'a manqué c'est le contact avec
les clients la diversité des activités
la diversité des métiers c'est un des
rares métiers qu'ils rencontrent tous
les autres métiers et ça me manquait
trop et donc du coup je suis retourné
dans cette profession
de votre côté donc du coup vous pouvez
autant aider vous êtes réalisé pour vers
les entreprises parce qu'on perd
également en fait à aider des
associations sur trois structures au
niveau des entreprises vous êtes là
quand ça va bien mais quand ça va mal
c'est quand une entreprise du couvent à
mal
l'objectif de la tour d'expert comptable
c'est qu'il est présent très
régulièrement auprès des chefs
d'entreprise c'est un peu comme je
disais lorsque j'étais jeune c'est le
médecin d'entreprise il est présent
régulièrement il intervient à ses côtés
pour les bons moments comme pour les
mauvais moments et lorsque c'est les
mauvais moments il se doit d'être
d'autant plus la de l'accompagner dans
la difficulté
opprimés régulièrement très bien alors
on a très peu de temps donc on va finir
ag si je peux me permettre sur la
formation c'est quelque chose qui fait
parfois un peu peur puisque à une
formation longue au final c'est 5 ans +
3 ans des stages rémunérés absolument
absolument les stagiaires qui sont
rémunérés chez nous donc on y font leur
stage d'expertise-comptable et/ou de
commissariat aux comptes et de
commissariat aux comptes ce sont des
gens qui sont tout à fait dans les
fourchettes du marché du travail donc
ils ont ils sont effectivement
stagiaires mais faut pas se dire que
c'est un stagiaire qui est entre
guillemets sous payés non il fait un
réel mais qui en même temps voilà et à
rémunérer l'état de créer en conformité
avec le le marché du travail
voilà tout c'est important pour le
signer mais je vous remercie tous les
deux d'être là faurecia présent sur ce
plateau on passe sa tournée suite au
magazine de la semaine
les grands prix d'innovation se tenait
ce lundi à paris parmi les entreprises
franciliennes en lice des yvelinois nous
avons rencontré les responsables de
centimes et au sel des eaux et de la
ruche qui dit oui ont-ils ou non
remporté un prix je vous propose de
suivre cette cérémonie avec des images
des lots diwan et jonathan vilma
palais brongniart à paris le 2 décembre
c'est ici que seront remis ce soir les
grands prix de l'innovation 2013 en
attendant la cérémonie les entreprises
finalistes s'expose dans ce salon en
tout 39 sociétés d'île de france et
parmi elles trois entreprises présents
dans les yvelines c'est léo la ruche qui
dit oui et sans timéo en quoi sont-elles
innovantes que propose-t-elle pour le
savoir nous avions rencontré quelques
jours plus tôt les responsables de ces
sociétés
celles des eaux est un site internet qui
permet de faciliter la prospection
commerciale
il permet d'accéder à une base de
données collaborative
le concept pour avoir accès à un contact
il suffit d'en fournir en clair un
échange de cartes de visite virtuelle
celle des eaux c'est le résultat de mon
espace commercial ça fait 15 ans que je
fais développement commercial que j'ai
des problèmes pour trouver des bases
pour trouver des contacts pour
prospecter et donc 7 0 c'est un peu la
solution à ces problèmes que j'ai
rencontré et j'ai eu la chance de
travailler aux états-unis de 2008 à 2010
et c'est aux états unis que j'ai
découvert le concept de la banane et
collaborative qui est à la base
finalement de l'offre de salle théo
lancé il ya deux ans ce site
communautaire compte aujourd'hui cent
mille membres qui échangent chaque mois
de vente à 30 mille contacts autant
d'informations qui renforce sa base des
données et c'est là que la société peut
devenir rentable ça crée beaucoup de
valeur autour de la base de données de
la formation l'information elle est
assez riche la presby to be et donc nous
on fait on vend aux entreprises au
directeur commercial au directeur
général qui voudraient équiper ses
commerciaux avec celle des eaux à ce
moment là il peut payer un abonnement à
7,0 et ses cotations un accès illimité à
la base
à l'origine de 7,04 associés dont
olivier candau un ancien collègue du
fondateur depuis sept salariés ont
rejoint l'aventuré il ne compte pas
s'arrêter là il envisage pour l'année
prochaine une levée de fonds d'un
million d'euros ça va permettre
d'accélérer le développement
de constituer une équipe commerciale
d'abord on est une entreprise
commerciale on cherche à vendre qu'on
développe notre marketing qu'on continue
à développer notre produit on a aussi
des ambitions de développement à
l'international pour aller rapidement en
espagne en angleterre en allemagne en
suède
benjamin du pays et tiny montain depuis
maintenant deux ans il propose aux
franciliens de recycler leurs pièces
rouges ces pièces de 1 2 ou 5 centimes
avec ses distributeurs chewing gum ou
gels antibactériens vendus à l'unité au
prix de 5 ou 10 centimes on n'est pas
essayer de capter battre avec les autres
pour capter des flux monétaires où il ya
un flux monétaire qui existe et dont
personne ne veut donc une hétéro mettre
quelque chose en face car ces fameuses
pièces rouges sont généralement mal émis
par les gouvernements car elle coûte
plus cher à frapper que leur valeur
faciale et par les citoyens en europe il
en existerait 60 milliards pour la
plupart sortis du circuit monétaire est
perdue au fond d'un tiroir benjamin
s'est lancé dans cette aventure
entrepreneuriale à seulement 21 ans deux
ans plus tard il s'est entouré de deux
collaborateurs mais toujours étudiant
une situation parfois compliqué ou quand
on est étudiant face à des prestataires
on n'est pas du tout crédible donc en
plus on n'a pas le droit de venir et
donc ça nous permet pas d'avoir cette
excuse qui font permettrait de
flexibiliser l'agenda car benjamin gère
à la fois rendez vous commerciaux
développement du concept et installation
des machines la semaine dernière il en
pose et une à la gare de saint quentin
en yvelines envers tout seul et on fait
les installations sont ça peut-être
changé c'est l'avantagé start-up une
quarantaine de ses distributeurs sont
aujourd'hui en service ici la communauté
d'agglomération a été pour lui un lieu
de test il compte désormais s'étendre en
nous de là là on installe les premiers
distributeurs de monodoses immature hier
dans le métro à partir du 12 décembre et
après nous on est sûr de tous les
produits d'hygiène qui de consommation
quotidienne qui peuvent intéresser les
usagers en milieu en espace urbain
objectif 1500 machines d'ici trois ans
chaque mois ils récupèrent le produit
des ventes de 100 à 200 euros par
machine pour le moment les jeunes
entrepreneurs vise une rentabilité d'ici
fin 2014 une victoire au palais
brongniart pourrait accélérer la donne
dernière entreprise en lien avec le
département est présente au grand prix
la ruche qui dit oui où il ya quoi ou
circuits courts le principe un site
internet qui met en relation
consommateurs et producteurs locaux un
particulier une entreprise ou comme
c'est le cas ici attrape une association
peuvent devenir responsable d'une ruche
une ruche c'est un lieu comme ce hall
d'immeuble où se réunissent une
communauté de consommateurs et des
producteurs résident à moins de 250 km
333 ruche existe dans l'hexagone dont
une soixantaine en ile-de-france la
ruche de trappes fête son premier
anniversaire
cette inimitié n a tout de suite aimé le
concept parce qu'on voulait privilégier
les petits producteurs locaux -
l'émission payent le même prix voire
même des fois pour certains produits un
petit peu plus cher on sait au moins à
qui ça va ya pas un intermédiaire et
puis on a des très très bon produit donc
on est content continue le site se
rémunère à hauteur de 10% des
transactions tout comme les responsables
des ruches l'opération rapporte chaque
mois à irène près de 200 euros 11 ruches
se sont déjà implantées dans le
département remporter un grand prix de
l'innovation permettrait au concept de
s'étendre davantage
retour au palais brogniart nous
entrepreneurs et compétiteurs sont loin
d'être stressés on est aujourd'hui dans
la tente du résultat qui va tomber ici
un quart d'heure et on espère bien voir
gagner à nous on pense qu'on a
une offre qui est assez forte et pense
que on l'a déjà peut démontrer que ce
qu'on a dit 1000 membres qui utilise
elle et on a des clients
après je sais pas si on alors que la
plus sexy l'heure du verdict est arrivée
la cérémonie commence les entreprises
concourent dans huit catégories près
d'un millier ont postulé mais le jury
n'a invité ce soir que les finalistes
cinq entreprises pour chacune des huit
thématiques
c'est maintenant au tour de la catégorie
de services aux entreprises nous y
retrouvons la société d'olivier picard
perdu il reste une chance de voir nos
vies noire remporté un prix sont timéo y
la ruche qui dit oui sont toutes deux
finalistes dans la catégorie services
aux particuliers attention roulements de
tambours
de cette catégorie est la société la rue
fille oui
et un tonnerre d'applaudissements pour
la ruche qui dit oui centimes et où ne
peut que s'incliner marc david l'un des
deux associés bien chercher son prix il
y a deux ans il avait déjà tenté ce
concours sans succès il tient
aujourd'hui sa revanche cette
reconnaissance lui assure un bel avenir
plus on a de visibilité nous niveau de
la plate forme internet plus les régions
de la visibilité plus à fonctionne plus
à gauche qui ouvre est bon mais c'est
plutôt une dynamique positive place
maintenant au cocktail de clôture nous y
retrouvons benjamin qui n'a pas tout
perdu ce soir on n'est pas si déçu que
ça on a un peu surpris parce qu'on
pensait qu'on avait de bonnes chances de
la loi maintenant ce sera peut-être
l'année prochaine mais bon quoi qu'il
arrive c'est vrai que c'est pas dans les
concours que se construit l'entreprise
et ça c'est vrai qu'on le sait et
aujourd'hui on est plus heureux le ce et
reporter sur la ratp et ses nouveaux
contrats dont on sait que l'essentiel
est là en fait ils comptent déjà se
représenter l'année prochaine même son
de cloche pour les associés de 7,0 ya
toujours le type est d'aider
participe à un concours pour gagner mais
on est très content d'être nominé
d'avoir est en finale et c'est belle
soirée
quand même content on tentera peut-être
une autre année qu'il soit vainqueur ou
non ce soir c'est champagne pour tout le
monde
et deux dates à retenir dans cet agenda
dans le cadre des rencontres de la
maison de l'entreprise vous pourrez
découvrir comment construire sa
stratégie de communication rendez vous à
la maison de l'entreprise à montigny le
bretonneux mardi 10 décembre de 9h30 à
12h et puis l'université populaire
organise jeudi 12 décembre à 20h30 une
conférence sur le thème crise financière
crise économique comment s'en sortir
elle sera animée par mehdi litim rendez
vous au prisme dans le quartier 17 mars
à elancourt c'est la fin de ce fil échos
je vous souhaite une bonne soirée et
vous donne rendez vous la semaine
prochaine